our first speaker is Malika who's going
to talk about exit learning take it away
thanks Rob so this is joint work with my
colleague Tara jvd and my students
teaching and song by external look like
they made it looks like we made it to
the adviser stuff okay
so the problem we are going to look at
is classification so you know let me
just quickly remind you but this is a
you know very basic problem with Xin
learning we have vectors of features we
have discrete labels let's say red or
black and we want to find a prediction
rule in a class for example here it
could be the class of linear classifiers
to predict Y from X ok so the problem is
if you want to build an accurate
classifier you often need a lot of label
data right but label data is really
quite hard to find right so you know
unlabeled array is cheap so you can
download a lot of documents from the web
or a lot of images from Flickr
but to get label data you need somebody
to kind of painstakingly read these
documents and you know label them as you
know label them the topics are you know
you need somebody to then go through
actually look at these images and label
them with objects that they have so what
we are hoping to do in active learning
is we are hoping to use interaction to
get around the need for so much
annotation right so we are hoping to
save on annotation which is expensive
because it requires human effort to by
using interaction in the learning
algorithm itself ok so here you know
remember this was our basics task given
X iii's you find a prediction rule to
predict Y from X's and for active
learning oops sorry
and for active learning this tasks is
the following so now instead of X I buy
eyes you have X eyes and what you could
do is you could make interactive label
queries to an annotator
what you're going to get is
you know so you make some interactive
label parties and hopefully these label
queries are much more strategic than
asking for every label and why by using
this kind of interactive label queries
your hope is to develop a prediction
rule by using much fewer label queries
than you would have normally needed
right by using much fuel or by using
much much less annotation cost and it
would have normally need it okay so why
does you know I didn't expect this kind
of thing to help so let me show you a
very very tight example right so just
bear with me for a little bit because
this example is really very toy and
there are things that are wrong with it
and I'll come come to it okay so let's
say you get these bunch of unlabeled
points you ask for that one and they've
see a red now let's say you ask for this
one you see a black you ask for that guy
you see a red glass for this one it's
red right and now you can say oh well
you know here's the linear classifier
because this is the only line that is
gonna separate you know these four
points into reds and blacks so you know
this is my line right and here what is
going on is instead of labeling all
these points what you see is that you
just needed four labels right and you
know because you could ask these labels
physically and interactively you managed
to get away with having much fewer label
okay but there is in fact a catch and
the catch is incorrect responses right
so when I when I showed you that example
then underlying assumption that you had
when you used your strategy for failing
levels was that the knave of search you
got we're all correct right and when the
labels are you know incorrect so to
speak that doesn't you know quite happen
right so you know one quite a common
setting in machine learning is you know
what is what we call agnostic learning
so we will talk about it a little bit
more formally later
so suppose what happened was you know
you were given unlabeled data you could
make interactive label queries and you
didn't really have any assumptions on
the data distribution right so the data
distribution doesn't have to be you know
the the reds and the blacks don't have
to be perfectly separate separated by a
line you know it is what it is and what
you want to find is you want to find a
line that
you know that separates most of them
right and here you wanted to do active
learning so here what could happen is
you know maybe you follow the strategy
that I showed you before but maybe this
was your correct labeling right so here
and see what happens is that one is the
best classifier to line in with the
dotted line that's the best classifier
okay that that makes the you know that
separates you know that has the least
classification error but if you follow
the strategy that I was using before you
would completely miss it
right and what you would do I mean even
if you were given a very high labor
budget what you would do is you know you
would kind of hold on to this region of
the space and it would keep making a lot
of queries around here right and you
know even if you had an infinite amount
of labor budget it would keep making a
lot of queries around here and really
perfect that line whereas the drill that
the best line actually lies very far
away okay and this is really the
challenge in active learning and this is
what I'm going to call statistical
inconsistency right so what do I mean
loosely by statistical inconsistency
what I mean is even if a label but this
is infinite you are going to converge to
a local minimum right you're going to
define this local minimum or not but
you're going to converge to a local
minimum and you're going to miss out the
best classifier altogether okay and this
is kind of a challenge that arises a lot
in active learning and this is something
that we have to you know we have to be
careful that we don't fall into this
trap okay
and so in this talk we are going to talk
about so that was kind of a very you
know cartoonish overview of active
learning in this talk we are going to
talk about you know not just getting
feedback where you know where the the
where the feedback that you get is
labels but it was like bit slightly
different kind of feedback and this is
you know this is the the kind of
research this is a kind of agenda that
you know we have been looking at for and
not not just as like a lot of people in
the community have been looking at for
the last few years and I will talk about
two kinds of you know different feedback
in this particular talk and this is you
know based on some of our previous
papers
the first one is when we have weak and
strong labelers and this is join for
pitchy Chang and the second one is when
we have labelers which sometimes say I
don't know and this is joint birthweight
song by and my colleague taraji meeting
okay so let's start with weak and strong
laborers and let's start by taking a
look at the model okay so for okay sorry
so for first it let me start out by
giving so so let me first start out by
telling you a little bit about the model
and then you know we will talk about
weak and strong labor okay so the model
that we are going to use for this weak
and strong label our problem is what is
called a pack bottle or the probably
approximately correct model I'm sure
many of you are familiar with it but let
me just do a cartoon overview anyway so
here what is happening is you have a
concept class C and you have samples X I
and why I let you draw from some data
distribution B right
so as a concrete example your C could be
a class of linear classifiers right
and your goal would be to find a
classifier in your class which has no
error under the data distribution right
so there are the souls so there's a
couple of things to observe here so one
is that the error I am measuring the
error with respect to the underlying
data distribution so in general you
would never really know you know you
never really know what your underlying
data distribution is you have a bunch of
samples from it but so but but this is
our Bowl right is to get C with low
error with respect to the data
distribution so you have to in fact
worry about you know is the sample error
representative of the broader area so
you have to worry about these kinds of
things so so that is you know so that
that is our our goal in this problem
so we will look at two versions of the
PAC model that shows up quite a lot so
the first one is the realizable case
where there is a perfect classifier
right and you know so that probably you
know as you can guess really happens in
practice but it's a
simple abstraction the second one is
when that's not the case right so you
know so you can see in this picture here
there are pluses and there are minuses
and there's a little pocket or minus
says inside the pluses and you know it
doesn't matter what linear classifier
you have nothing can separate all the
pluses from all the minuses right so
here what we want to do is we want to
have essentially no assumptions on the
data distribution and our goal is to
find the best classifier in a class that
we can okay and so this leads us to end
this is called diagnostic model so this
essentially leads us to agnostic active
learning so which is the formalization
of our problem we have a concept class C
and the best classifier in C has error
you know let's just say has error NuStar
we are given a bunch of excise and we
can make interactive label queries on
these excise and our goal is to find a
classifier in C with error at most new
star plus epsilon using very you know as
few label queries as we can and when we
have no assumptions on D okay so this is
essentially a formal statement of our
problem okay so what kind of algorithms
can be used in this case well for the
basic problem so this is the problem
when you know you are getting label
feedback from from your annotators in
this case there's the there's a fair bit
of work and essentially there are three
classes of algorithms for the agnostic
problem that applied to the agnostic
problem so one is called the said women
based active learning and you know a lot
of people in this room have worked on
this problem
blombo I think bagels Ivor Balkan a
lankford Chanukah Dasgupta honey c'mon
that's good pursue Monte Leone and many
others and then there is also
margin-based active learning this is due
to Balkan Broder and Shang and also you
know Balkan along and more recently you
know we have shown that this is related
to confidence based active learnings and
finally there is
you know clustering based active writing
this is the first work on this was right
that's good pen so and then you know
this with more recent work by owner at
all and this work what we are going to
do is we are going to base this on the
settlement based active learning so that
that would be what we both okay and let
me also give you a very quick overview
of the settlement based active learning
the main idea here is that you maintain
a candidate set of classifiers that
contains the best classifier NC and your
unlabeled data comes by one after the
other so if an unlevel data point comes
by and if there exists two classifiers C
1 and C 2 in your set in your candidate
set that that differ on its label then X
is in the disappointment region of V and
then you're going to query the label of
X and you're going to update V
accordingly right so you know unlabeled
data comes by you maintain some set of
classifiers which could be your best and
you know as unlabeled data comes by if
there is some disagreement then you
query the label and based on the label
you keep updating B okay so what we are
going to look at today is we are going
to start with this framework and we are
going to look at what happens if we have
auxilary information in the form of an
extra or
so an example of this would be so let's
say you want to label medical images you
have a doctor you know you have a
physician who's whose time is valuable
but who is who's going to give you their
you know who's gonna think about it and
who's gonna give you the correct answer
or you can have let's say a medical
resident who is you know whose time is
less valuable with answers that you get
might be sometimes wrong right so this
is the kind of setting and in this
setting how do you combine you know how
they combine annotations from weak and
strong laborers to make good predictions
so that's essentially the question that
we are asked so going back to a model
you know what does this mean for a model
we again have a bunch of X sites and
instead of YS we are allowed to make
interactive label queries and these
label queries could either be to the
oracle right which is you know think
about the oracle as a doctor
after the week labeler right oracle o or
weekly Bueller W or you know how to auto
both if you want okay and your goal is
to find a prediction rule to predict Y
from X s using few label queries to all
right so as a simplifying assumption we
are assuming that you know queries to W
are essentially free what we'll see is
that we will need really that many
queries to W they won't be words and
standard active learning so we are
assuming that queries to W are
essentially fee but we want to use a so
what we want to use is as few label
queries to O as possible okay and
formally again now we have a concept
class C where the best classifier has
you know some error and you start with
respect to O and again you have a bunch
of excise and interactive queries that
you could make either to the Oracle Oh
or the B cleverly W your goal is to find
a concept in C with error
NuStar plus epsilon and here the catch
is that the error is this is with
respect to O while minimizing the number
of label quiz tool okay so here what we
are assuming is that the Oracle is the
ground truth and we are trying to
approximate the Oracles labeling
function using the best concept in in
the class okay so this is this is the
safety okay questions until now okay
excellent so what does this mean right
so you know I give it all this math and
I give it a small bottle you know what
what does this mean what does this model
mean and what kind of problems can arise
in this model so the kind of problems
that could arise in this model is that
the week level RW may be biased right so
what do I mean by this
so let's say this is the labeling
function and this is W labeling function
right so what is happening here is there
is this region in the middle where W
just completely gives you the wrong
labels right and in and this region you
know it's it's not like a random coin
toss you can't ask W 100 times and get
better results by averaging you know
this is some of the things that you
could do in to outsourcing here you
can't do them because the labels are
just biased
so previous work so before our word
there had been some work on this
particular setting there was you know I
know it all they looked at explicit
making explicit assumptions on where WI
know differ and you know they assume
that double you know or gonna differ
close to the decision boundaries and
then they had some interesting results
there was another work by I think Jessa
Bianchi at all where they didn't have
explicit assumptions but they just
looked at in a robust regression and
online online learning so online so this
was a workshop paper in news 2014 and
they looked at online selective
classification and robust regression and
this before what we are going to use is
we are going to look at you know general
learning strategies so basically
classify learning strategies by
combining labels from W&O without
explicit explicit assumptions can you
actually achieve that without knowing
ahead of time I mean I guess what maybe
get to that but I mean so in some cases
W wasn't biased that's right so if W
wasn't biased then then in in theory you
were right you could you know
technically like keep asking W a lot of
times so here w could be biased and
which is the reason you know the crux of
the problem that we're trying to this is
which is what makes a problem hard yes
you're absolutely right this so the
flipside of Rob's question is if w
provides no information so w always says
-1 that is absolutely true and here that
that is that will come across ok so how
do we learn in this model and here is
kind of the main idea right so we are
going to learn a difference classifier H
that will predict where onw differ and
then we will either use H as a filter
with standard active learning to decide
if we are going to query or efficient
query W right so you know Percy find out
by one W differ then you use this you
know difference you know filter kind of
thing as a filter bit standard active
that ok so that's kind of the idea so
you know this is the algorithm you train
you know you query a bunch of points for
both onw
figure out if the differ treatment
difference classifier run standard
disagreement miss antimony so they don't
make any explicit assumptions about W so
I know you're thinking that this might
pick as many samples as you know for the
active learning but we'll come to that
there's this yeah that's definitely true
but we get around it suits and Strix so
we'll come to that ok so this is the
algorithm outline ok now what could be
the problem with this you know so first
of all you know so let's say let's
forget about labels right is this even
statistically consistent right and
actually the answer is no and this is
you know one of the key observations
that we made ok so why not let us look
at this particular example right let's
say this is the actual example you know
the this is the Oracle Oracle labels the
entire space at yellow ok and sorry yeah
the Oracle they've the same type space
as you know if you look at w w is going
to label that corner over there it's
great ok
now you know in this case if you want to
find if in this case if you sorry so in
this case if you run this algorithm and
if you want to find eight star well this
is the H star right so let's say we are
looking at eight star as linear
classifiers this is the H star that best
predicts the difference between you know
best predicts by oh and w differ this is
a region but they differ this is a
region but they don't differ so here
you're going to query oh here you're
going to query W right
what is the annotation that you're going
to get well if you if you do this
strategy if you query you know one W
here and you know if the strategy gives
you annotation this is the annotation
you will get right which is not all
sanitation okay and so as a result if we
use this annotation to strain your final
classifier your final classifier won't
really be you know it's not always
labeling function right so your final
classifier be it'll be sadistically
inconsistent okay so how do you get
around this well we can actually use
something simple which what we will do
is we will essentially use a cost
sensitive difference classifier okay so
our observation is that if oh and w
differ and we said that they don't
differ that is kind of dangerous right
because that could lead to an
inconsistent annotation whereas if they
don't differ and we say that the differ
well that's just some extra queries -
all right so we can afford to make those
kinds of mistakes so that is essentially
our so that that's essentially our
strategy instead of training you know a
different size of fire will train a cost
sensitive difference classifier where we
constrain the false negative weight to
be close to the false negative error
rate to be close to zero okay and in
fact if you do this then as you can see
you will probably be a little bit more
conservative in terms of where you query
oh but what will happen is you won't be
inconsistent right so the statistical
consistency will be maintained so this
is this is the solution to that problem
so this is this is basically what you
get
okay so then this is our algorithm you
you know you trained a difference
classifier now it has just false
negative error rate and less than equal
to close to epsilon now the question is
fine so now you know we have the sound
rhythm what about its label complexity
and you know we have my label complexity
we'll just use the number of four is two
all right we don't care about W very
much okay let's see how many labels you
need to train a difference classifier in
fact as it happens you need about D
prime over epsilon labels to train the
difference classifier where D prime is
the VC dimension of the difference class
and you know this is bigger than the
label requirement of you know sometimes
it's even bigger than the label
requirement of active learning itself
right so the question is can you know
can we do something about this okay so
for this we use so here comes in our
second observation so the second
observation is you know so imagine you
have your entire input space and you
have your disagreement region right so
currently you know remember we had this
candidate set of classifiers we looked
at where these classifiers disagree
which was two disagreement region and
that's where we would query labels right
everywhere else we know what the label
is okay now the second observation is
that we don't really need our difference
classifier to work outside this
disagreement region right all we need
for our our different classifiers to do
is to work well inside this disagreement
region and so and so it's okay to train
the classifier just restricted to this
region and this is essentially what is
going to help us so basically what we
need is our is the disagreement region
then the false negative rate of the
difference classifier has to be epsilon
over the probability of our or there's a
probability mass so far and so
essentially the number of labels we need
is oh of the prime times probability
mass of R over epsilon right and
probability this R is keep going to keep
shrinking
as you label you know as you train more
and more this art is going to keep
drinking more and more right and as a
result you'll be okay because you know
overall this will work out okay and so
again you know our keep shrinking so
that's a kind of a side problem our
keeps changing and shrinking and it
keeps changing so what do we do well you
know we have to be pre-training a
resolve okay and this gives us the full
algorithm so we do an epic based
algorithm in epic key you know we target
excess error of epsilon K this is about
1 over 2 to the K we start out with a
confidence set VK which has the cerumen
region disagreement of VK and then we
draw a certain number of samples from
this region and query onw
right so don't worry too much about this
particular number essentially just like
even thing to keep in mind is this is
just enough samples to get false
negative rate epsilon K over that
disagreement region that's you know
that's what that number means it's I
know it's a little complicated then you
tre aquario NW and then train a
difference classifier and then you would
run the segment based active learning
algorithm to target the excess error to
target excess error epsilon k and then
you know if a query is the label of X
then you know then yeah
and then basically use this you know a
will use your the difference classifier
that you learned then a is going to use
the difference classifier as a filter
right to decide whether it's going to
play you orbit is going to probably
double you so formally weaker here is
like the set of all pass pass with no
regret the false negative edge bounce
so again just to give you a slight you
know now this is probably the next few
slides are going to be a little bit
technical so how do we measure the exact
label complexity remember the label
complexity is measured by of the
sacrament this active learning is
measured by the disagreement coefficient
which I guess Steve came up with and so
I'm going to just use kind of a
simplified version of it so it's not the
best version but essentially the idea
here is the disagreement coefficient a
way to think about it is it's the make
of change of you know the probability
mass of the disagreement region as you
shrink are right so R is you know all
you know all classifiers at a certain
distance and then you know as you shrink
are the disagreement region of these
classifiers also shrink right so this is
essentially the rate of change of the
disagreement region and so usually what
happens is okay so this increment region
so here the total number of labels to
train the difference classifier would be
d prime times the disagree times theta
of NuStar plus epsilon over Epsilon
okay and for the rest of active learning
we again need you know sorry this part
is a little bit technical so for the
rest of active learning we need to
define some measure of how much the O
and w differ and how well this is
predictable so what we even do is we
were you know we will make a couple of
assumptions so the first assumption is
that essentially there is a classifier
which has low false negative error over
the disagreement region right so there
is an age which has low false negative
area and then you know alpha R T
essentially measures the rate of
positives of this age right so here the
thing to remember is that frrt is always
going to be less than equal to the
probability mass of the disagreement
region and if you you know and then you
can again talk about the rate of change
of alpha and that you can measure by
Sigma so imagine Sigma is like a
corresponding term to
of the disagreement coefficient but this
is measuring something a little bit more
complex and so what you would get is the
number of labels for active learning
what you would get is d Sigma Nu Star
squared over epsilon Square where Sigma
is the rate of change of this you know
of this region whereas what you would
get for disagreement bass active
learning is instead of Sigma you would
get setter right and then the thing to
remember is Sigma is less than equal to
theta if Sigma is much better than theta
then you can get again okay and it could
be equal to theta in the case that
Akshay mentioned when you know W is
completely random or W is completely
biased then it would be equal to Sara
but you know in the cases that it's not
then you are able to get again yeah we
don't quite cover that other extreme so
this is I guess the point of this
algorithm is to cover the bias you're
right the other extreme we haven't
looked at in this case that's an
interesting so when you say a little bit
of miss state with respect to what
because this goes through in the case
when the let's say you are looking at
linear classifiers the oracles labeling
function is not linearly separable but
what this will do is it will find the
best classifier in the class may not may
or may not use it but even whatever the
Oracle is using it's a struggle right
cool place not right but then what is
perfection so but they're either
labeling so the liking your doctor case
there is a correct labeling but even the
doctors me right but then you know you
have to have some signal from that
labeling right so if you don't have any
signal from the labeling the best you
can do is approximate the orator who's
the best approximation so okay so this
was active learning that we can strong
label s the next what we are going to do
is we are going to talk a little bit
about active learning with abstentions
and you know this kind of came up in the
last dog is I think a lot of people were
asking Adam oh are you label is going to
say 5050 all the time or you know what
happens if they say I don't know so you
know this is kind of the answer you know
this is also some of the things that you
could do when the label let's say I
don't know so so what is the what is
that so what is the setting when the
setting is that you know you have again
you are doing active writing sometimes
when you ask you know these kinds of
questions to labelers why do you know
even something label has already been
experts but you know mostly when you ask
these questions to non experts whatever
what's going to happen is that the
labels are going to abstain on the more
difficult examples and if you force them
to give a label then you know they're
just gonna give you something gibberish
or you know if they have this option
then they're gonna you know they're
gonna say I don't know okay and what we
are going to do is we are going to look
at take a you know kind of take kind of
a formal look at you know can be exploit
this abstention somehow to learn better
what are the conditions under which we
can do this there is a bit of empirical
work including some by JD on on a
related topic in this work we are going
to just a kind of a formal look and try
to understand when we can say something
over here okay so next let's start out
with kind of a very basic and simple
example suppose what we are looking at
is a concept class of thresholds and we
have some instant space of 0 to 1 you
know this interval is in some space and
we are looking at a concept class of
threshold circle and let's say there is
some underlying ground truth so we are
changing models a little bit over here
we are not you know we are not in the
side Gnostic model anymore they're
changing models a little bit here so
there is some underlying ground truth
sea star okay and so what is a model
where basically the learner can query
any X in X okay so again this is a
little bit different it's not just
allowed to query the labels of the
excise so this is you know this is what
a lot of learning theories would call
the membership query model so you can
query any X in X so we're just doing
this as a simplifying assumption any X
in X and it will get a bunch of
responses so the responses could be plus
or minus or don't know and they're going
to be drawn from some unknown
distribution P of Y given X right so
there's some probability which depends
on X whether you're going to get a plus
or a minus or I don't know right and
what we want to do is our goal is to
find a concept see so here a concept is
going to be our threshold right to see
such that the gap between C and C star
is at most Epsilon right so here you
know again there is no data there's no
underlying data distribution really we
can make you know any query b1 but what
we want to get is something that is
geometry really close to C star with as
few queries as we can write and you know
the queries could also give you an
abstention results so let's start out by
trying to understand when can
abstentions right suppose this is our B
of y equal to abstain given X right so
here notice what is happening is you
have your C star but you know the
absence you made a sort of random right
so it has it's not really telling you
anything much about C star it doesn't
tell you anything but you what's going
on it's you know going up going down
it's really kind of random right and you
know this kind of abstention right well
you know maybe we can throw all the
abstentions but beyond that this is not
going to be super informative
here is another example of the kind of
abstention rate you could get right so
here what is going on this is our C star
which is the you know this is a decision
boundary and as you get closer to the
decision boundary that sanshin weight
sort of goes up so which basically means
that you know as you get closer to the
decision by already your examples get
more and more difficult so you know it
makes sense you know gets more and more
difficult and then the label as you
start saying don't know
we're off okay and you know and it
doesn't really have to be symmetric or
anything but essentially you know the
idea is that it goes up as you go closer
and closer to the decision boundary and
this kind of abstention rate you know
this might give us some information
because you know as we see them going up
we can see oh okay this looks like
they're getting closer
right you know they're starting to say
don't know so these are the more
difficult example maybe we can do
something over here interval around C
star so that then you can only achieve
certain right exactly so so then what
would happen is so what Rob is saying is
if what if the abstention rate this one
in an interval around C star so what
would happen is you could use our
algorithm to get to that interval and
then you would be stuck did you fake
this assumption up in a high tension
right means you know boundary into the
algorithm where is this something right
to discovery in other words can I flip
the red curve and I could just have a
really weird expert who upstairs a lot
you know extreme so we need the
abstention rate to you know we don't
need the we do need the abstention rate
to go up or like not decrease as we go
closer to the boundary
okay so this is essentially a model and
now let's look at you know a plausible
algorithm okay so you know the basic
algorithm that you know so so let's
start with what happens but we don't
have abstentions right so this is you
know a very basic thing the absolute
basic algorithm active learning
algorithm ever write the binary search
okay so you start with an interval which
contains C star let's say you even get
correct responses okay so now you have
an interval containing C star you know
you make a query you get a plus you know
now you know what C star is lying on
that side right so you divide the
plausible interval by half right then
you keep going on until you know you've
gotten to epsilon so very very simple
okay now what happens when your queries
are noisy so you know when you you know
when you make a query and you may not
get the correct label it's flip with
some probability so here again you can
query multiple times so you're very
multiple times you know you will do some
averaging and you will get the ground
truth table with high confidence okay
and you know this will also work when
your noise rate is increasing because
what you could do is you could
adaptively decide how many queries to
make right so you make some queries you
do you know so there are standard
results that you could use this one is
by Bala Subramanian Ramdas so what you
could do is you could say okay I made
these many queries this is how many
zeros and once I saw this is my
confidence on whether this is you know
the the probability of you know whether
this labor was going to be plus or minus
right so you can say this kind of thing
you know standard confidence online
confidence intervals and then you know
you can even still do this kind of thing
okay now we are going to start out with
that algorithm and we are going to start
out by making it handle abstentions okay
so for abstention instead of doing a
binary search what we will do is you
know so let's say we have a potential
interval we are going to query and the
quartiles of the interval right so we
will make three queries and white three
will become clear very soon so we will
make I guess one fourth you know median
and 3/4 right first quartile median
third quartile we are going to make
queries and you know will make a bunch
of queries and after each query
we've again it you know adaptively
determine if we are confident in the
label at any of these points okay
if the abstention rate is increasing in
some direction okay so for example here
what might happen is in OVC maybe you
know so I can't draw that many pluses
and minuses but we know maybe here you
see five pluses and one minus and one
abstention and then you can say okay so
you know after my hypothesis test I'm
pretty confident that this is going to
be a plus and so you know then you know
the label and you can you can truncate
off the interval right or what you could
do is you could you know you could
similarly decide that a label was - or
you could figure out that you know based
on these based on responses at you know
cotton you could figure out that that's
tension rate is going off in one
direction and then you could decide okay
so looks like that sunshine rate is
going up in this direction so seaside is
in that direction
nice modern is that you have a ground
truth and your ground truth is going to
be your response is the ground truth it
doesn't have to be additive so the
response is you know there's some py
given X right exactly exactly
yes it's non-persistence yes
non-persistent noise yes so so you can
determine if they are confident the
label at any point or if the abstention
rate is increasing in some direction
right and based on this you can truncate
okay
and so again so you know coming back to
the question of why do we need three
because the reason why we need three is
if we want to determine the direction in
which the abstention rate is increasing
if we had to you know then one with one
we can't really figure out if the
abstention rate is increasing with two
what could have
then is you know these could have the
same abstention rate because it went up
in the middle right so that is why we
need three so performance guarantees so
this algorithm is in fact you know does
not need to know any parameters or py
given X and here's essentially the
answer to your question so this will
work correctly this will get you close
to C star so this statistic it will give
you the correct answer so long as the
abstention rate does not decrease as you
move closer to the boundary right so you
had abstention rate you know stays the
same it will get to there and then maybe
then it'll get stuck or if your
abstention rate increases then it's good
for the algorithm it will manage to
exploit this information so long as the
abstention rate does not decrease close
to the boundary this algorithm will be
fine and so what about the number of
queries so again you know this is the
one slide where I will get a little bit
technical so you know we have kind of a
fairly complex sort of analysis which
gives you the number of queries what I'm
going to do is I won't go into the
details of the analysis I will just
explain with one example which our
analysis covers okay so the example is
suppose your abstention rate looks
something like this right so
representation rate looks like 1 minus C
0 X minus C star to the alpha right so
what what does this mean so this is your
C star at C star your abstention rate is
1 right and you know it goes down you
know kind of like this right and you
know the the rate at which it goes down
is measured by you know C 0 or the
distance between X and C star to the
Alpha okay and let's say your noise rate
is less than equal to half minus C 1
times X minus C star to the bellow
okay so again you know the noise rate is
sorry your noise rate is 1/2 at the at
the decision boundary and then you know
it goes down and as sine beta are
greater than equal to 1 so essentially
if you just have this this would be you
know kind of like the Seebeck of noise
condition so this is a corresponding
version
of this for abstention is a
corresponding version of the civic of
noise condition for abstentions so in
this case the number of queries to get
to C minus C star less than equal to
epsilon so to get to distance epsilon
would be you know by Abaddon log factors
o of epsilon to the minus alpha okay and
if you just use labels and you know if
you just use labels and if you threw out
the abstentions what you would get is o
of epsilon to the minus alpha minus
twice better right because you know
essentially you're throwing out the
abstention it was you know for each
label you need to get you know
essentially when you are really close
for each label you need like 1 over
epsilon to the alpha abstentions so you
know you're paying the abstentions and
you're paying to get like the you know
to average the labels and you need a lot
of ways right whereas here I what our
method is doing is that it's essentially
using the signals from abstention and as
a result it's doing much better and you
know we have so our result in its full
generality talks about you know what
happens when it uses both labels and
abstentions and so on and so forth so in
full generality it is quite complex but
I want to just give you this example to
illustrate what it is that it's doing
okay
so finally here's a summary what we
learn is that abstentions might help if
the rate of abstentions increase close
to the decision boundary and you know so
the you know so we can we can do
something when this case holds and we
can you know I told you about our
algorithms for thresholds but this also
extends to smooth boundary fragments you
know kind of like the Castro Novak
results we can get it to extend to
smooth boundary fragments and you know
we've been looking at the pac-man also
this is kind of work in progress so
conclusion you know I started out by
talking about active learning with more
complex feedback than labels
so essentially you do you know you can
get more complex feedback to help active
learning but you know not always you
know as generally is the case it will
help you under certain favorable
conditions however we need
we'll use fairly sophisticated algorithm
so we need to really think about when
they're in the interaction is helping us
or not and we need to use algorithms
that are a bit more sophisticated than
just using simple label feedback okay
and with that I'll take your questions
like that I'm thinking of a lot of real
applications where maybe you have some
initial sort of classifier that maybe
was developed by some rules of thumb or
something else you know you're saying or
maybe it's just been developed for
general purpose but you want to kind of
adapted to the specific case of an
individual user Oracle so in that hey
have you thought I mean I guess there's
no reason why that couldn't fit the role
of the we play blur and then you could
personalize the classifier or customize
it to a particular Oracle that weighs
absolutely so you're absolutely right
and so so so one of the things I didn't
mention is so the problem we are talking
about is the problem of essentially
domain adaptation right so where the
data distribution could change a little
and the labeling function could change a
little so what we are dealing with is we
are dealing a domain adaptation when
that when the labeling function changes
so we haven't talked about what happens
when the data distribution changes so so
long as so my point is so long as in
your new application the underlying
distribution of X's does not change this
solution will very easily go through we
would need something a little bit more
if the underlying distribution of
existence
you'd intuition of what happens in
slightly higher dimensional space like
2d so in total what we are looking at
are essentially smooth boundary
fragments so they're what people do is
we would do multiple 1d problem so we
just break it down into a bunch of 1d
problems and then we would solve them so
it's a non parametric setting so we
break it down into multiple 1d it so
that actually poses some interesting
constraints on what the uncertainty
yes absolutely absolutely yes that's it
was the epsilon to the minus alpha
result is that optimal ah so excellent
question so far 1b I believe we have a
lower bound that lower bound doesn't
quite extend to the D dimensional case